مرحباً، اسمي ديفيد براون وهذا درس في القراءة والكتابة.
أن تكون مقنعاً في تواصلك سيكون مفيداً لك، لدراستك، لمستقبلك
المهني، إلخ.
أن تكون أكثر إقناعاً في تواصلك سيكون مفيداً لك.
أن تكون أكثر إقناعاً يعني أن تكون قادراً على جعل الآخرين يفعلون ما تريد.
أن يفعلوا ما تريد، بالضبط.
كيف تكون أكثر إقناعاً؟
حسناً، عليك أن تتعلم، كما يقولون، سمعت مرة، بمجرد أن تعرف الجمهور الذي تتحدث إليه،
عليك أن تتعلم كيف تتحدث بنفس الطريقة التي يتحدثون بها حتى يتمكنوا من فهمك بشكل أفضل.
ولكن في نفس الوقت، بنفس كلماتهم، وبنفس الطريقة التي يتحدثون بها،
عليك أن تعلمهم شيئاً ما.
وبمجرد أن تعلمهم، سيكونون قادرين على اتباعك.
أعتقد أن كل شخص لديه شيء يمكن أن يقنعنا به إذا كان لديه القدرة
على فعل ذلك، تلك المهارات التواصلية للتحدث والتعبير عن أنفسهم بشكل جيد.
ليس الأمر سهلاً.
لا، ليس سهلاً، أتفق معك.
قد يكون صعباً.
وهذا شيء يمكننا تحسينه.
يمكننا أن نتعلم كيف نكون أكثر إقناعاً في تواصلنا.
وهذا شيء يعلمنا إياه فريدريك دوغلاس (Farīdrīk Dūghlās)، إذا قرأت سيرته الذاتية وسنقرأ
جزءاً منها اليوم، ستلاحظ كم هو مقنع.
إنه حقاً كاتب جيد جداً، كاتب مقنع عظيم من أجل هذه القضية.
وكان لكلماته تأثير كبير لأنه كان مقنعاً جداً.
إذن، لنلخص هنا، من كان فريدريك دوغلاس بالضبط؟
يمكنكم رؤية مجموعة من الصور هنا.
هذه من فترة ما قبل الحرب الأهلية، ومن عصر الحرب الأهلية.
يمكنكم رؤية أمثلة أخرى لدعاة إلغاء العبودية (du'āt ilghā' al-'ubūdiyya) في هذه الصورة هنا.
لقد ولد عام 1818 وتوفي عام 1895.
كانت ذروة نشاطه خلال الحرب الأهلية، لقد كان مصلحاً اجتماعياً أمريكياً من أصل أفريقي، وداعية لإلغاء العبودية،
وخطيباً (khaṭīban)، وكاتباً، ورجل دولة.
هل يمكنك أن تقرأ لنا هذا الجزء هنا؟
بعد هروبه من العبودية في ماريلاند، أصبح زعيماً وطنياً لحركة إلغاء العبودية.
مشهور بخطاباته وكتاباته القوية؟
ممتاز. في الواقع، كان أبراهام لينكولن يعرف عن هذا الرجل وقرأ كتاباته.
وكانت بعض كتاباته هي التي ألهمته للانضمام إلى هذه الحركة.
لدينا مخطط هنا.
سنفكر فيما نعرفه بالفعل عن فريدريك دوغلاس،
ربما ما أخبرتكم به بالفعل، أو ما سمعتموه من قبل، أو ما تعرفونه عن
الحرب الأهلية بالفعل. ماذا تعرفون بالفعل عن هذا الداعية لإلغاء العبودية أو عن الحرب الأهلية؟
مما أخبرتني به، حسناً، هو أمريكي من أصل أفريقي، كان عبداً.
تعلم القراءة من الآخرين.
لم يُعلَّم كيف يقرأ، ولكنه تعلم من خلال سماع الآخرين يقرؤون، أليس كذلك؟
وقد توفي عن عمر يناهز 77 عاماً، وهرب من العبودية في ماريلاند.
وبمجرد أن تعلم القراءة، كان  مشهوراً.
كان كاتباً مشهوراً.
كاتباً. داعية مشهور لإلغاء العبودية وكاتب. ممتاز.
أنت مستمع جيد. شكراً لك.
الآن، هناك أشياء جديدة لنتعلمها هنا. ما هي أسئلتك حول فريدريك دوغلاس؟
ما هي الأشياء التي تود أن تعرفها عنه؟
أوه.
حسناً، يُقال إنه هرب من العبودية. ماذا فعل بعد ذلك؟
نعم.
وكيف تعتقد أنك ستكتشف ذلك؟ حسناً، أعتقد أننا يمكن أن نكتشف ذلك من خلال دروس وأنشطة اليوم،
ولكن في الواقع ما سنقرأه اليوم يتعلق أكثر بأفكاره قبل أن يهرب.
ما زلت أعتقد أنه يمكنك تكوين فكرة عما كان عليه أن يفعله أو ما الذي دفعه إلى التمكن من الهروب.
وهذا شيء آخر ربما ستتمكن من قراءته
بعد درس اليوم أيضاً إذا كنت ترغب في إنهاء قراءة سيرته الذاتية.
وبعض كتاباته. إذن لدينا بعض المفردات التي نحتاج إلى التركيز عليها. سنقرأ مقطعاً
من سيرة فريدريك دوغلاس الذاتية حيث يصف تصميمه على تعلم القراءة والكتابة.
لا شيء يمكن أن يوقف هذا الرجل. لقد فعل كل ما بوسعه لتعليم نفسه
في عالم كان فيه تعلم العبد للقراءة والكتابة من المحرمات الشديدة.
حسناً. هذه بعض المفردات التي نحتاج إلى معرفتها هنا. أود منك أن تلقي نظرة
عليها وعلى تعريفاتها. لدينا "strategies" (استراتيجيات - istrātījiyyāt). هل يمكنك قراءة التعريف لي هنا؟
حيل بارعة. حيل بارعة (ḥiyal bāri'a) أو خطط (khuṭaṭ) تستخدم لتحقيق هدف ما.
"Depravity" (فساد أخلاقي - fasād akhlāqī / انحطاط - inḥiṭāṭ).
لا أستطيع رؤيتها جيداً. فساد أخلاقي أو شر. شر.
ماذا عن هذه. "Chattel" (متاع منقول - matā' manqūl / رقيق - raqīq). الكلمة الأولى، كيف تنطقها؟
"Chattel". "Chattel". تبدو كأنها فرنسية، أليس كذلك؟
مادة أو ملكية شخصية. الأشخاص المستعبدون كانوا قانونياً
يعتبرون "chattel" (متاعاً منقولاً). لذا فهو في الأساس مثل شيء لا قيمة له. لقد عوملوا كمجرد
أشياء، مجرد أشياء يمكن استخدامها والتخلص منها. وهذه "precepts" (مبادئ - mabādi' / تعاليم - ta'ālīm). "Precepts".
قواعد أو مبادئ توجه السلوك. "Apprehension" (توجس - tawajjus / فهم - fahm).
هل تسمعني.
"Apprehension". هل تسمعني؟ "Apprehension".
خوف. الآن أسمعك. خوف وقلق من أن شيئاً سيئاً سيحدث. وأيضاً فهم.
لا. "Urchins" (أطفال شوارع - aṭfāl shawāri' / مشاغبون - mushāghibūn).
"Urchins" مشاغب. لا، لا أعرف كيف أنطقها.
"Mischievous" (mischievous). "Mischievous".
غالباً أطفال فقراء ويرتدون ملابس رثة.
هناك "sea urchins" (قنافذ البحر - qanāfidh al-baḥr). قنفذ البحر هو نوع من الكائنات البحرية ذات الأشواك.
ولكن يمكنك استخدامها لوصف الأطفال أيضاً، "urchins"، بمعنى إيجابي أو محبب.
وهذه، "vindication" (تبرئة - tabri'a / إثبات صحة - ithbāt ṣiḥḥa). "Vindication".
و "vindication". تبرئة شخص من اللوم. أوه، وإثبات. دليل على أن شخصاً ما أو شيئاً ما
صحيح أو معقول. و "abhor" (يمقت - yamqutu / يكره بشدة - yakrahu bi-shidda). "Abhor". النظر باشمئزاز وكراهية.
وكراهية.
لذا نستخدم هذا كفعل، أن "abhor" شيئاً ما، أن تكره شيئاً ما بشدة.
الكثير من هذه الكلمات تسلط الضوء حقاً على بعض الأشياء التي سنتحدث عنها من خلال
قراءتنا أو نقرأها معاً. عندما نقرأ، سنحاول التركيز على المعنى، على الرغم من أنني يمكن أن أساعدك في النطق،
لا أريد لذلك أن يعيق الفهم.